welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid over on the energy video
freeloaders full asked what the what did
you not at least explain equals
mc-squared
because it's too important to be just a
side note it deserves its own video nay
it demands it okay how should we start
this oh I know we can look at it piece
by piece
e equals MC squared that's energy equals
mass times the speed of light twice
let's start with the easy part
the speed of light well it's it's it's
the speed of light it's the number and
it's always the same no matter what so
you just look it up or you use it so
much you haven't memorized it's two nine
nine seven nine two four five eight
meters per second or a little over a
hundred and eighty six thousand miles
per second yeah I said per second was
that in there dude it's just a number
the word light isn't relevant that
number shows up a lot of places that
have nothing to do with light and it's
huge and there are two of them in there
that means this over here is a really
really really big number so much bigger
than any other energy we deal with
millions of millions of times bigger the
energy in me is a little over eight
followed by 18 zeros okay so what about
math smartypants Oh mass is a little
weird and it probably doesn't mean what
you think it means it has multiple
definitions all of which are completely
independent and slightly wrong you get
inertial mass for Newton's second law of
motion it says F equals MA or more mass
means more inertia which means less
acceleration you also get gravitational
mass from weight the G can be thought of
in two ways the acceleration due to
gravity or the gravitational field
strength but either way more mass means
more weight for hundreds of years it
perplexed physicists how come these two
types of mass always had the same value
but didn't seem to have any connection
with each other then Einstein came along
through thought experiments or her
doctrine for such I'm Stein discovered
many things one was that you can't tell
the difference between acceleration and
gravity fields so technically the only
difference between inertial mass and
gravitational mass is who's looking
physics is weird you're weird
you think that's weird Einstein didn't
stop there he came up with the equals
mc-squared but that's not the whole
story
technically how big this number is
depends on who's looking so we throw
another factor in there to take care of
that
the faster you see the thing moving the
bigger that factor is only when it isn't
moving can you say e equals MC squared
so we often call this rest energy and we
call this total energy weight total
energy yep total as in all of it whether
it's thermal chemical or nuclear all of
the energy inside this skin suit is part
of what I call my mass it all gives me
inertia and it all helps gravity work on
me there is no difference between mass
and energy and everything tangible
everything we are capable of touching
has mass so what's the weirdest science
fact you have ever heard please share in
the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
[Music]
[Music]